lo que tenemos aquí es un triángulo en
donde todos sus lados tienen la misma
longitud tienen la misma longitud y son
congruentes entre ellos a un triángulo
así lo llamamos un triángulo equilátero
triángulo equilátero ahora lo que quiero
hacer es demostrar que todos los que si
todos los lados miden lo mismo entonces
vamos a saber que todos los ángulos
también van a tener la misma medida así
que vamos a pensar cómo hacer esto
sabemos que ave es igual a hace y
supongamos que ni siquiera sabemos que
miden igual que veces y lo que sabemos
de un triángulo isósceles es que si
tienen dos lados iguales entonces
los ángulos de la base van a ser iguales
es verdad entonces el ángulo lo que
sabemos es que el ángulo
abc será igual al ángulo acb
ángulo abc es congruente al ángulo acb
porque
bueno este esta es la afirmación verdad
es la afirmación y vamos a tener nuestra
razón de por qué ocurre esto
entonces vamos a escribirlo esto es
porque los ángulos de la base de un
triángulo isósceles digamos activo ya
sabemos que es equilátero pero en
realidad lo que importa es que tenemos
dos lados iguales así que tenemos dos
lados iguales y esto va a implicar que
los ángulos base son iguales son van a
ser iguales y eso viene del último vídeo
que vimos para triángulos isósceles
también podemos ver este triángulo de
otra forma podemos decir que ahora este
ángulo de aquí tomando como referencia
este vértice entonces estos otros dos
van a ser los ángulos base así que como
estos dos lados son iguales tienen la
misma medida
entonces los ángulos base van a ser
iguales es decir el ángulo sep abi es
congruente con
este ángulo se ave va a ser congruente
con el ángulo abc
ángulo a veces que dije ah sí
a b c
ahora esto es por la misma razón verdad
tenemos dos dos lados iguales así que
sus ángulos base van a tener la misma
medida verdad lo obtuvimos en el vídeo
anterior así que es la misma lógica
ahora estos dos ángulos son iguales
y estos otros dos ángulos también son
iguales entre sí así que a veces es
congruente con acb y que también es
congruente con sea b así que todos los
ángulos son congruentes entre ellos ok
entonces obtenemos que el ángulo abc es
congruente con el ángulo acb que también
es congruente con el ángulo se ve verdad
entonces en un triángulo equilátero
tiene tres ángulos que son iguales o
congruentes entre ellos ahora si todos
miden la suma de todos los ángulos es
180 y miden lo mismo tenemos que x mas x
mas x es igual a 180 o bien 3x es igual
a 180 y si dividimos entre 3 tenemos que
x es igual a 60 grados entonces un
triángulo equilátero tiene todos sus
ángulos iguales y además todos miden 60
grados todos miden 60 grados
muy bien ahora vamos a pensarlo de otra
forma digamos que tenemos un triángulo
en donde todos los ángulos son los
mismos
todos los ángulos son los mismos digamos
este es el punto x punto y el punto z si
sabemos que todos los ángulos son
iguales ok vamos a poner que estos
ángulos son congruentes entre sí lo que
lo que mostramos en el último vídeo en
el vídeo de triángulos isósceles
demostramos que si dos ángulos son
iguales entonces sus lados
correspondientes también van a ser
iguales así que en este caso vamos a
tener que x el lado y x va a ser
congruente al lado
gz y sabemos esto porque los ángulos los
ángulos base que en este caso déjenme lo
pongo los ángulos bases son congruentes
entonces qué ángulos son el ángulo en x
y el ángulo en zeta
entonces también sabemos que el lado z
es congruente al x z
el lado de zeta es congruente con x zeta
por el mismo argumento nada más que aquí
vamos a considerar ángulos base
distintos verdad entonces digamos si
este vértice es el que tomamos como
referencia estos otros dos van a ser los
ángulos base y como estos dos son
iguales porque siguiendo el mismo la
misma lógica entonces tendremos que los
lados van a medir lo mismo verdad eso es
simplemente considerando ángulos
distintos como referencia entonces en
este primer caso
el ángulo el ángulo y xz era congruente
al ángulo zx-10r está equis y eso nos
generaba que x fuera congruente con
jay-z verdad y eso como les dije ya lo
vimos en el vídeo anterior ahora en este
caso
aquí tendremos estos dos ángulos base
que van a ser x y z el ángulo x y z es
congruente con el ángulo y x z
es esto y eso implica que receta sea
congruente con x z y ya lo probamos
entonces si x es congruente con jay-z y
jesse t es congruente con x z entonces
todos son congruentes entre sí así que
en este caso si todos los ángulos son
congruentes entre sí tendremos que los
tres lados van a ser iguales